okay
so I guess I can score in the middle I'm
going to talk about uh
some recent work that I've been doing
relating proof complexity to tfnp
okay so people who went to the boot camp
has probably seen Susanna's talk and
Susanna introduced a little bit about
this so you can think about this is just
kind of deepening her deepening what she
was talking about a little bit more
um so okay so let's first remember what
tfnp is okay so in the classical Theory
let's let rxy be some
uh
some NP search some NP relation okay so
this means that it's
polynomial time computable and it's also
polynomial time bounded right so uh so
given X and Y I can compute R in
polynomial time and if there's any
certificate for a given X there's
actually a certificate that's pretty
short it's polynomially bounded right
so given such a thing we can we get a
natural search problem right
if we're given some X
well let's define a y such that r x y
holds
right
does that make sense okay great
and of course this is like the standard
complete problem for function NP if you
like you know what I mean if I if I take
R to be given X is a C and F Formula and
Y is a satisfying assignment this is
like the complete that would be like the
complete problem for FNB okay so uh it
turns out to be interesting to ask the
question about what happens if this
relation is total so by total I mean for
every X there is a y such that the
relation holds okay
so in this case we're going to call the
we call the class of all such things
tfnp right this is the class of all
total total polynomially bounded
polynomial time computable relations
um and this has been used in complexity
Theory as probably everybody who's at
least somewhat familiar with to like
classify a lot of different problems
that are naturally told because a lot of
problems in algorithms and complexity
are naturally total things like a really
good example would be something like
Computing a Nash equilibrium right every
buy Matrix game has a Nash equilibrium
and so therefore it's natural to ask to
you know output a certificate of this of
course it doesn't make sense to ask for
the verification problem for these
things anymore because the answer is
always yes right if you give me X I can
always just output one what's really
interesting about this is actually the
search versions of this of these kinds
of problems right so okay so just like
uh just like in classical complexity
Theory we can define a bunch of
subclasses here
so this is say tsmp
in this original paper where uh tfnp was
introduced
um there were a bunch of classes
introduced these sort of classical tfnp
classes
um and they all correspond to nice
simple total search problems so let me
just write a few of these down
okay
and what's nice about these subclasses
is that each of them corresponds to like
a uh a theorem actually usually a
theorem that that involves a proof of
existence right so for instance the
class PLS you can think of as
corresponding to the theorem that
uh every dag has a sink
so in order to Define it formally we
would have some turing machine that's
describing some exponentially large dag
right and then you would want to find an
actual sink in this a sync node in this
implicitly defined turing machine and
then we would Define PLS to be the class
of all such problems that we can you
know solve by reducing to this single
search problem does that make sense
okay cool I guess there will be some
syntactic reason why it will be attacked
exactly right yeah we'll we'll hard code
in the definition that there's that
it'll be a tag say every node has some
fixed out degree
um like usually the weight sound is like
we have we equip it with some potential
and like we have to we say that the edge
can go forward only if the potential
decreases like we're equipping it with a
Transit ordering
okay cool
um okay and then maybe just for another
example I mean pad down here
this corresponds to a directed version
of the handshaking Lemma right
so in other words what this means is
that if I have a directed graph and I
have some unbalanced node like it has
more in degree than out degree and
there's got to be another unbalanced
node with you know more out degree than
any degree right
and the complexities of these things
have been sort of very well studied so
because of this connection with these
natural theories it's natural to believe
that a connection to proof complexity
should exist and indeed there is in fact
even in one of the original papers I
mean it was observed that if any tfnp
problem is NP hard this happens if and
only if MP equals co-np right so this
would this should suggest that there's a
connection to complexity and what I'm
going to talk about and what I'm kind of
interested in working on and what I've
been working on is really deepening
these relationships okay so to define
the connection to proof complexity
um it turns out the right thing to do
is to talk about blacks box versions of
tfnp
okay so Susanna defined this but let me
just
let me just sort of quickly go over it
again so all that in order to go from
the classical world of tfnp where
everything is defined by an algorithm
what we're going to do instead is we're
just going to replace every polynomial
time algorithm with an efficient Black
Box algorithm what is that well that's
just a decision tree of polylog death
does that make sense
so
please
algorithms
with
Only log depth
okay so I mean maybe just to give a sort
of sort of an example here uh in order
to define the like a relation now
you know we would have say the input is
to is now a decision tree it's got some
in bits the output is going to be some
you know some certificate and the way
that we'll Define efficiently
certifiable is very simple for every
output there's a there's an efficient
decision tree that you can just check
that'll check if it's the right thing so
for every possible output
there is a decision tree t
zip step
you know rxy holds if and only if e x y
relation between black box and being a
decision tree you can do this query
algorithm every query algorithm you can
model as a decision tree right
if I have a polynomial time algorithm
and it's got an oracle well I can write
down queries of size roughly log n and
so I can make polynomial queries to it
that's basically the connection
s
it doesn't really make a difference yeah
yeah
um Okay cool so now what you can do is
you can take all these classes and you
can just kind of plug in this decision
tree everywhere
so now the only difference is that all
of these problems
are now going to be defined by using low
depth decision tree reductions instead
of low depth polynomial time reductions
let's not worry about exactly how you
define that but this is just basically
how you do the extension
questions so the definition of decision
tree doesn't exclude doing things that
are not just queries to the black box
or I don't know
maybe we can just take this discussion
offline yeah because I'm not quite
following what you're saying
um
okay so we can take like the decision
tree versus these classes defined by
efficient redemptions right
um and when you do this something pretty
cool happens
and so so what happens well every
Susanna Susanna mentioned this in her
talk but every
NP search problem total search problem
like this we can associate with it a low
with unsatisfiable C in the formula and
what the CNF formula says basically is
that this problem is not total
which is of course impossible because it
is total pranked so you know I could
Define this F sub R by
you know a big and over all the
certificates that you know none of the
certificates hold
and since this is a low data decision
tree I could write this as a low width
scene
that makes sense
and this right here is the connection
between proven
and searching in total search problems
okay so now tfnp is associated with the
set of all bounded with unsatisfiable
CNF formulas
and these lower with classes turn out to
correspond exactly to persistence which
is kind of the amazing thing and this is
what we've been working on
so let me just maybe in my last couple
minutes let me just say some of the
characterizations and separations we can
prove so
um
it's kind of this classical result and
it was even in
Susanna's talk
that P down here corresponds to
tree-like resolution efficient tree
light resolution proofs
um PLS here corresponds to
uh
bounded with resolution so let's say
low width
resolution proofs
so these results were both known in the
literature they weren't explicitly
stated in this way but if you go through
the literature you can find you know
they basically had already proved this
like this wasn't this sort of wasn't new
um our contributions have been to show
that these other classes also correspond
to really nice group systems so for this
class PPA it turns out that this is
exactly
null still insets over F2 which if
you've seen Tony's talk
you'll recognize it as an algebraic
proof system
um ppad corresponds to null still
insects over the integers
and ppads corresponds to
Shirley Adams
just like the program from the classical
proof system from linear programming
albeit with low coefficients
yeah
um and
this is only a small fraction of the
kinds of things we can use
um and maybe one more nice result to
mention is um there was this beautiful
result recently
by uh
showing an intersection theorem
namely that
P pad intersect PLS
is a well-defined class turns out to be
equal to this class CLS
this was by this was best paper at stock
I believe a couple like a year or two
ago
um so we were able to improve this
to show that it's actually equal to this
end of potential line problem and our
reduction even works in the Black Box
setting
we can also get the same thing if you
put in an S for pad you can get sync a
potential line
which is a natural sync version and it
turns out that these have nice
characterizations as proof systems as
well which is a pretty amazing thing
actually
um so the sync a potential line problem
turns out to be exactly
turns out to correspond to the proof
system
which comes from Max set solving called
reversible resolution
and a really really cool result here is
that
reversible resolution is somehow exactly
the intersection of low width resolution
and low coefficient trolley atoms which
is my opinion is a totally weird result
I've never seen a result like that in
complexity before so in general
something that I'm really interested in
working on for the rest of the semester
is obviously to continue pushing this
there's a lot of results that I haven't
mentioned that we've we have many
results in this sort of direction that
we haven't mentioned but in particular
one thing I'm interested in especially
in light of the meta complexity stuff is
to understand strong proof systems
really strong proof systems can you
somehow understand the complexity of
things like Fraga or extended Fraga or
even other kinds of proof systems using
this kind of language because it seems
like once we hit those that level of
complexity we need more complexity like
standard complexity type assumptions to
sort of understand what's going on
okay that's it
thank you very much
maybe next speaker Marshall can set up
while we ask questions
yeah in a paper we just submitted
uh we characterized for SK and also
we've we've been able to characterize
it turns out like there's you can take
rescade and you can Define like a higher
depth generalization of Charlie Adams
and making characterize that as well
some other things
we in upcoming work we think we can go
higher yeah we're working on that right
now yes
what is the tfnp do you have some
corresponding proof system for tfnp tfnp
is literally the set of all bounded with
CNF formulas so they're unsatisfiable
CNF formulas that's this correspondence
right here so that's how you should it's
there's no real proof system for it I
mean if there was a proof system for it
then PUD and people come in P right so
tfnp is like the set of all so
unsatisfied seamless so PPP those
beloved that's a great question PPP is
really missing here this corresponds to
the digital principle we do not have a
proof system for it like a nap like a
naturally occurring one that exists in
the literature already
we don't have one then I'm kind of not
sure if they're even this one in some
sense
so in this the formula FR is it always
is the representation important is it
always a CNF or uh because these so here
you talked about which proof systems you
refuted in yeah but does the
representation come in somehow yeah it
is important so I mean like you can kind
of think of this as giving like a theory
of reducibility for proof complexity
like that exists in standard complexity
like what this is saying is that there's
some fixed CNF formulas such that you
can prove something in the proof system
efficiently if and only if you can
reduce your tautology to that formula
efficiently so the representation really
does matter actually like the
representation tells you kind of what
class you're operating in
and that reduction the efficient
reduction would also be in some black
box yeah position tree exactly so it's
like a local efficient reduction
maybe we'll take other questions offline
or one quick question
okay thanks again
[Applause]